that's [__] great there man only fan
that's such a great business model
insane right damn I remember when they
were going to go away and then all the
fake only fans popped up yeah and we
spent like 30 grand to get a [__] uh
plug talk website built and then by the
time it got done only fans seemed a lot
more stable and so we never even ended
up making the website go live we figured
let's just stick to only fans yeah it's
almost like if you YouTube went away
you'd have to figure some [__] out like
only fans is kind of like the new like
standard if you're a content creator
even yeah in the porn industry and I
even know girls like some of the biggest
girls in the industry who have their own
website ready at to go and they just
keep it on the back burner because only
fans is just so much more familiar to
the users that it's just it's a layup
like it's just it's just so much more
effective to put your content on there
it's kind of sucks you can't necessarily
like present it exactly the way that you
want to present it like you would be
able to on website but they go to your
website they got to put in their credit
card information they go to only fans
credit card information is already in
there for like almost everybody who
would ever think about buying porn right
true yeah and it's kind of like if
you're going to go on YouTube to watch
like all your content why would you go
sign up for I mean like shout out to
rumble no D to rumble but I'm not
[__] watching nothing on Rumble I
mean I would if it came down to it but
like if you had to if I had to I would
go to rumble but it would take a lot
yeah it would take a lot especially like
if you got like booted off the platform
or something yeah exactly has happened
with I think what Steve will did happen
happened with him yeah it's it's good to
have a backup but I don't know um do you
guys get to see like uh like the top
earners CU we saw the celebrity top
earner of the Year thing on only fans
are you able to see on the back end like
where you ranked at the end of the year
they tell you your like percentage like
like you get to see top 00 1% yeah but
they don't give you any more information
than that cuz it would be that would be
pretty crazy if we were able to be like
well we make a little bit more than you
and you but not as much as you that
would be cuz I I I feel like some of
these celebrity numbers have to be
inflated I think a lot of people lie
about it and like the bad baby numbers
are so [__] insane yeah I don't know
a weird part of me kind of believes her
numbers just because as ridiculous as
that $18 million month looks it just
kind of seemed like when I when I saw
how it went from like 18 million to like
800,000 as the months went by I was like
that seems like a normal rate of uh you
know degrading of of income but I don't
know if you saw the guy who was like
Ruby Rose's number one I saw you just
did interview with him he said it was
cap right yeah and so I feel like I
think he's full of [__] oh no no that's
that's a funny reaction that a lot of
people keep having to it is that they
think he's actually now covering up for
his own perversion but let me tell you
I've known this guy for a long time so
you know him I I've known him because he
used to be a an assistant to a tattoo
artist who did some work on me he one
time came to the store in like 2018 and
he did a a dab with lean instead of
water uh I guess he was just trying to
get some attention doing that or
whatever and the thing about him that
really made me realize it was fake is
well number one one of the top dudes at
only fans corporate told me it was fake
and then after that I realized just that
he knows a lot of the pornstar girls
that I know like he was on FaceTime with
Gina Valentina right after our interview
just talking on some regular [__] so
it's like he doesn't seem like the kind
of guy and and also I don't think he has
the kind of money that it would require
he's supposed to be a crypto whale I
think yeah that's you think that's all
[__] yeah no so cuz he was I saw a
picture he didn't get a Ruby Rose Tattoo
he did get a Ruby Rose Tattoo I don't
know which is kind of funny cuz I doubt
she would ever want to really see him
again that's very uh that's that's
committing you want to know something
super funny oh my God I feel bad
actually I feel bad even calling it
funny but he had a whole week of media
planned out right he was going to do
Vlad he he he flew to Miami to do
freshman fit immediately after our
interview you and he was supposed to go
on that whatever pod we've been dming
each other well there's another one that
probably isn't going to happen I would
assume but like the whatever pod when I
went there yesterday he asked me about
that guy I told him it was fake he goes
oh we're probably just not going to have
him on then I'm like oh whoops vad I
think canceled on him as well fake and
he flew out to do fresh and fit and they
canceled on him when when he after he
already flew out there but I I
understand why because what the [__] are
you interviewing this guy about if it's
all fake yeah especially
I mean shout out to Ruby Rose if this
was her team like hiring some dude it
[__] worked yeah I don't know I mean
it's not a bad
idea I told Mya girl right away as soon
as I saw that I was like we should do
this we should say that some guy give us
100 Grand let's just up the find some
dude hiring some [__] dude that's a
nobody who doesn't have any relationship
noal media presence they made it seem
kind of real with the screenshots of the
oh with the texting and [__] like weird
dude from only fans that was smart they
they and even this right here is kind of
like another round of attention on Ruby
Rose's only fans even if it's and I've
noticed too like you'll scroll on like
uh Hollywood unlock and they'll have
these fake stories about like teacher
gets fired from their only fans account
but it's really like we banged her oh no
no but I'm not even talking about that
one cuz that was a real one there's been
so many cuz we talk about [__] on the
radio and my my boy will be like oh this
is uh some some somebody got fired from
their job or whatever or and then we'll
look and be like oh this is a paid ad oh
yeah and now Twitter will add a
community note often times informing the
public of oh this is fake like this
account got paid to post this this is
only fan promotion yeah so shout out to
that's a very useful service right there